I recently did a things in this video on
the nun teaser trailer so if you haven't
seen that clicker tap up here to view
that video one of the things I mentioned
was how the nun has been teased and
other conjuring films so if you want to
see all of those references you know
what to do stick around to the end of
this video starting with the first
conjuring I'm gonna regret that if they
end up coming out with a movie called
the first conjuring or some [ __ ] but
starting with the conjuring the warrants
have this room filled with cursed
objects from their previous cases it's
the room that holds the Annabelle doll
before the Annabelle spin-offs were a
thing and it also has this picture of a
creepy nun keep in mind this is before
the face off against VALIC the nun demon
in the conjuring - so there may be
something at the end of the nun where
the characters think that they've
trapped value in this painting but in
reality it's just a mother spirit we may
also see the event that causes VALIC to
hang out with the Warren family a
poltergeist that persists through the
conjuring - later on if you pause during
the scene where Carolyn Perron hears
clapping in the house in one of the
pictures on the wall you can clearly see
the nun standing behind the family okay
okay I'm kidding that's that's probably
just the daughter it does look a little
bit creepy though I can't lie and I
think that's actually it for the first
movie though this was before we even
knew this would be a big franchise but I
think this room of trinkets is a clever
way to tie the series together and we
may even see spin-offs of other objects
from this room I mean I know I'd watch a
movie about this monkey wouldn't you the
next movie to come out was the first
animal okay okay the next movie to come
out was Annabelle in 2014
there aren't really any specific
references to the demon valack but you
can spot some nun imagery like this
statue or this statue of a nun these are
probably things that would be there
anyways just because the father of the
church is such a central character to
this movie one thing that I found could
be significant but I'm not entirely sure
is the music that plays when the record
player kicks on towards the end of the
movie if you reverse that audio it
sounds like a church choir or perhaps a
demonic church choir however I'm not
sure what language it's in I'm gonna
roll this clip and if you have any ideas
about deciphering it let me know in the
comment
you
[Music]
[Applause]
now the conjuring 2 as I mentioned is
all about valley so it's obviously gonna
contain a lot of appearances but in the
spirit of the title of the show I'm
gonna stick to the less obvious ones the
movie opens with a snippet of the
Warrens investigating the a medieval
haunting and as Lorraine has her
out-of-body experience you can spot a
nun painting on the bedroom wall there's
also a nun figurine in the daughter's
room and in the basement
it all leads up to this reveal phthalic
has been haunting Lorraine and her
family since at least in 1976 then later
on in the movie Lorraine mentions that
the vision that she had in a medieval
was the same one she had 7 years ago
meaning that Valcke has been around her
family since at least 1969 the demon in
your painting is real we have both seen
the same inhuman spirit it's a warning
if we keep doing this you're going to
die
weird stuff starts happening after ed
warren wakes up from a dream in which he
saw the demon and couldn't get it out of
his head
the name VALIC starts appearing
everywhere first on the wall in the
kitchen then in the daughters Arts and
Crafts a couple of nights later letters
start appearing in the study where
another nun statue appears during one of
the rains visions she ends up writing
the name in her Bible during a state of
panic after the wardens head out to
England to try to help the Hodgson
family there's a scene where the church
choir music originally heard in
Lorraine's vision can be heard coming
from the kitchen of the Hodgson house
and the daughter Janet claims to see a
pair of eyes riding in the dark
this is most likely her first vision of
VALIC in its nonfarm valley tells her to
destroy the kitchen to get the public to
believe that the whole thing was just a
hoax and to reduce the possibility of
intervention from the church but the
chapel music and the sounds of knives
sharpening tells me that she really does
see the demon hiding in the dark it's
not long after when ed and Lorraine
Warren realized the spirit of the old
man haunting the house is being
controlled by the demon and everything
after that is quite obvious that is
until the end credits the end title
sequence is accompanied by a series of
photos some of which compare the actors
in the movie to their real-life
counterparts as you might often see and
based on a true story films the photos
are displayed on an old slide projector
so when switching from photo to photo
there's a bit of a gap that lasts a
fraction of a second sometimes though
instead of seeing the transitioning
projector in between frames and images
displayed it's usually a photo of the
house and some of them contain the old
man sitting in the chair if you pause at
just the right moment or go frame by
frame one of these photos shows the
demon VALIC standing over the old man's
body
I was actually somewhat startled to come
across this because I had no idea it was
there another frame spliced in depicts
the demon standing at the end of a hall
as seen earlier in the movie at the
Warren residence I don't know why but
the face is blurred in each of these
photos and nothing else here's another
shot that's displayed one frame later
this one could be more of a teaser
towards the nun and then there's this
lovely portrait which is the last one
before the credits roll and we move on
to Annabel creation and it takes place
away before everything else meaning that
it's way closer to the time period that
the nun is set in the name of the nun
who watches over the orphan girls is
sister Charlotte and in one scene she
tells about a photograph that was taken
when she was in romania of her and three
other sisters keep in mind that Romania
is where the next movie is set so this
is probably a direct reference to
characters who will appear in the next
film that sister Maria
that's sister Ana in that sister Lucia
who's this
I don't know I don't think I even met
her oh yeah yeah excuse me uh uh I think
I have a couple of ideas but yeah as I
mentioned in the previous video there's
also a post-credits sequence set at that
abbey in romania which is also seen in
the teaser for the nun if you like this
kind of video well then obviously we
don't may awake but there's also this
video where I talk about everything in
jigsaw that sets up for the next
installment in the Saw franchise so if
you're interested in that you know I
mean you could always give that one a
wash just a suggestion if you're new to
the channel welcome feel free to hit
that subscribe button for new Horrors
every week I've got more things you
missed scary stories and short films so
make sure you ring that death Bell for
notifications and I will see you in the
next one assuming we both survive